on day three infantery and Megan's South
African tour we finally saw the face of
the third member that little of the
royal family remember when we first met
Archie all we saw was his little nose so
Archie came along when the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex sat down with one of
South Africa's heroes Nobel Peace Prize
recipient Desmond to toe Desmond Tutu
rather Debora patta looks at the wider
significance of this morning's meeting
it was a moment worth waiting for
a very animated baby Archie carried
proudly in his mother's arms while a
beaming Prince Harry looked on
Archbishop Desmond Tutu known
affectionately as the arch maybe
seriously ill but seemed energized
displaying his trademark smile and
infectious laugh
well correspondent Roy Inachus is the
first biracial British Royal baby
meeting a South African icon should not
be underestimated
a man who has campaigned for anti upon
anti apartheid and and for equal rights
for most of his life so there's history
in the making there and that's how he
Megan sending a very powerful message
with what was quite a lovely informal
meeting but very significant and
throughout that meeting his first
official engagement as a member of the
royal family for CBS this morning
I'm Debora patta in Cape Town South
Africa very Wiggly is it wishful
thinking on my part or did we see a
little bit of Auburn tint to it there
baby carrier carrying the diaper bag
Harry's got it